was it you or the Magnus that said that
cheating poses an existential threat
I mean there is some aspect of Truth to
that which is like
you know we the chess is in a state
where Bots uh chess engines are much
better than humans yeah and we're living
in a world where technology becomes
easier and easier to integrate with with
human beings whether you put in some
orifice or elsewhere and that that does
pose a threat to
um to our ability to trust that a world
champion is indeed a world champion that
somebody we think is good is indeed good
and so there is some aspect to the
ecosystem
that should punish cheating and perhaps
over punished cheating and the other
thing is
in sport you can take PDS and have
bigger muscles bigger better reaction
time but you still have to perform the
action in a successful way there's still
a chance you can lose
if you take Peds
maybe in some sports the gap between
non-ped and ped user is significantly
more noticeable but
in chess
if you cheat
you play God
yeah you decide when the game is over
you can fake bad moves
you can fake everything you can even if
you're cheating quote unquote the right
way you're gonna lose plenty of games
to avoid getting detected so you can
create Bots that are 2 800 like you can
also just not listen if you know all the
best moves but choose to play on your
own oh I made a mistake not a big deal
you could yes Bots are all at a
different level but if you were to cheat
that you you play God you can decide
when you make your move and when the
engine makes its movement if you know
the top four lines of the engine you
choose the fourth one so in hindsight
people will analyze your game and they
will go oh it wasn't perfect well no
[ __ ] only the stupid cheaters play the
top Engine line the whole game